MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, special relativity.
We're going to continue our
discussion of galactic space
travel.
Here the situation is slightly
modified from the previous one.
We still have Alice being
our ground control and Bob
riding on a spacecraft in order
to explore planetary systems
and solar systems.
This situation is
different in the sense
that the spacecraft
has an escape rod.
So it's able to send probes to
planets in order to study them.
And so, in this specific case,
the velocity of this escape rod
is uB delta xB over delta tB,
as measured in Bob's reference
frame.
The direction of this
velocity is the same
as the direction
of Bob's spacecraft
when looking in
longitudinal direction.
Again, as a reminder, velocity
is distance over time or delta
x over delta t.
So the question now is,
what does Alice observe?
Because this is an activity
you should try to work out
yourself, stop the video.
I'll just continue here.
So, if you calculate now the
velocity as seen by Alice,
delta xA over delta tA, that's
given by gamma times delta.
We just use Lorentz
transformation-- gamma times
delta xB plus v times delta
tB over gamma times delta tB
plus v over c squared delta xB.
Now, we can cancel the
gammas and take out
delta tB out of the brackets.
And then we find uB plus v over
1 plus v over c squared uB.
So this looks like an
addition of velocities
with a correction factor of
1 plus v over c squared uB.
Good.
So does this make sense?
So, whenever we have a
calculation like this,
we should check that
it actually works out,
that extreme cases
are preserved,
and that units work out.
So, again, the
units work out here.
On both sides, you
find meters per second,
the unit of velocity.
If you check now what happens
if we set uB equal to 0,
we know that the
escape rod is at rest.
There's no velocity with respect
to Bob's reference frame.
In that case, we
find that uA is equal
to v, exactly the
velocity difference,
the relative velocity between
those two reference frames.
If that velocity is 0,
we find uA equal to uB.
Again, that's expected.
If Bob and Alice are in
the same reference frame
and they observe
the same escape rod,
they better measure
the same velocity.
And, lastly, if we now, instead
of having an escape rod,
we send a beam of light
out, which has a speed--
a beam of light has the speed
of light, uB equal to c,
we find that the velocity
observed by Alice
is also c, which brings us
to an interesting point here.
Yes, we still add
velocities with a little bit
of a relativistic
correction, but we will never
get larger velocities
of the speed of light.
So the speed of light is
an absolute speed limit.
Let's analyze this
a little bit more
in the context of
our light clocks.
So what now happens if
the velocity is equal to c
is that gamma goes to infinite?
And, in the context
of the light clock,
you can notice that the upper
mirror can never be reached.
It's moving with
the speed of light,
the same velocity
as the light itself.
So light is never
able to reach this.
The clock will stop.
All right, so there's an
absolute limit of velocity
at the speed of light.
OK, so now, so far, we
discussed only velocities
in the direction in which
the two reference frames move
or the second
reference frame moves
with respect to the first one.
What now happens if we consider
perpendicular velocities?
So, in this case,
Bob's spacecraft,
this escape rod goes up.
Maybe he's circling the
planet, or he's just
approaching the planet.
And [INAUDIBLE] when
it [? pops at ?]
that planet specifically.
So here we want to work
out the example in which
the perpendicular
velocity is not 0,
but the longitudinal
velocity is 0.
So what does Alice observe?
So we do this as a
concept question.
Which of the four
answers is correct?
Is the velocity
unchanged because we
are studying
perpendicular velocity?
Is the velocity
smaller, larger, or you
don't know because
you actually have
to figure it out, work it out?
OK, so the velocity,
as observed by Alice,
is actually the absolute
value is smaller
than the one observed by Bob.
We can do the very
same calculation.
So we have uB y is
delta yB over delta tB.
And then, for Alice, this is
uA y delta yA over delta tB.
So the y-component,
the length measured
in y-direction
between Bob and Alice,
is invariant, as we saw
in the previous section,
but the time is not.
So we do have to do the Lorentz
transformation of delta tA
and find that, in the case
where uB x is equal to 0,
that we just have to
divide uB y over gamma.
Situation is a little
bit more involved
when there's also a
longitudinal velocity,
but you see here how
this would unfold.
So 2 was the
correct answer here.
So, while the length in
longitudinal directions
are invariant, the
velocities are not.
And that's because
time is suspect.
Time needs to be corrected
in the two reference frames.